The joe rogan experience of the bad people.
Sure.
Tell me the punk kid story because I'm frustrated.
What are you frustrated about?
Because I love that song.
That song has not died.
We you want to hear a song first?
Yes.
Okay.
Whatever you want to do.
Let's play bad people.
I'm going to take these off and thinking.
Is that Okay Jamie?
I'll just sing.
We just won't put it on our next record.
Yeah.
Okay.
Good move.
The legend will grow.
There were some a record company in congruencies that like,
I know you weren't able to do the things we wanted with it and it's a really
tested it by saying,
wait,
good move.
It's a good song.
It's a,
it's a weird song to song.
It's got a lot of layers to it.
It's a lot going on.
Lot going on.
That song.
They got a weird shit.
I think I would usually go,
can I?
We can we just do it?
Hi.
I'm the gatekeeper.
Just send them out front yard,
which in the rain in Paul,
so on.
You got to see
judge your best to be the worst.
You must like,
hey,
that show Kirsten.
Oh,
ah,
Jimmy was it broken?
Sangoma out.
Ellen nut bread.
Like a pimple
on his nose.
He was bloody all his life.
He cashed the check.
Ready?
No lovers off friends to it.
Dan,
hold on.
Stop Chimney.
Add some darkness.
Parsley's out.
We all got some darkness up,
asleep,
some pools down and some push through
baby.
It's a toss up.
How you do maybe some on the sides for you.
Maybe you don't even get,
uh,
hi dog.
No,
not
come from no
god.
Damn you got
both of you,
both of you for being so awesome.
God Damn,
that was good.
You know what was really cool?
People that are listening to this only you don't know that Suzanne adjusted
Ben's glasses in the middle of the song.
That's Ben's glasses started a slab and Suzanne like Lego,
like a mama bear came over.
Set you straight.
It happens some but it in the middle of like singing without missing a beat.
It was beautiful.
Well.